my guest tonight is a hilarious comedian
who just launched her new i heart
radio podcast the nikki glazer podcast
please welcome our really good friend
nikki glazer nicky
how are you conan i'm so good
it's so good to see you i love you well
i love you
that way no that's i know and you read
it just as we rehearsed it
um you look amazing i want to say that
first of all you
have looked absolutely gorgeous i know
you're down in the cayman islands it
agrees with you
you have this ethereal glow
i well it's it's two ring lights and um
fake eyelashes and uh i've literally
painted my body
to look like i've gotten sun because i
tend to stay out of it but yeah i'm
i'm in the cayman islands i've been here
i'm shooting a show
that i can't really talk about but it's
the best time of my life conan
in the canaan islands it's 2019 here
there's no covet and
if so when i got here i quarantined for
two weeks and now
you just go out and about and you have
to wear a mask like it is
really and that my ears just uh lost
my ears are so small they won't stay in
um
so little um so you can go out now
in in in public and i'm living like
before covid
and my first stop mask list was the
grocery store
and i i do have the answer for everyone
in the united states who's like what's
it
to be like when was like normal how long
will it take to adjust
yeah what's it going to be what's it
what tell us what it's like
you'll be back to normal by aisle five
like it literally
the excitement wore off so quick i was
coughing on people
halfway like trying to get them out of
the way so i could you know reach the
oatmeal i wanted to grab and i was
sampling the milk i mean like you're
you're instantly back to normal and so i
can
and i can confirm with everyone who is
here
from the states is like yeah you were
over it instantly it was novel for a
second
and but the thing is everyone's like
super horny for everyone because now
people's mouths are just like out and it
almost looks like
it's it's just like a nudist colony for
faces now where you're just like
his mouth is like right there like i
can't believe it's just out like you
could just like kiss
anyone and you just never thought of the
world that way so you think we shouldn't
do that but
well wait a minute i want to explore
this you're saying that when the masks
come off
because we're so used to not seeing that
the the mouth and that part of the face
when it comes off
we become hypererotic and we start
thinking about the mouth it's it's you
never
knew it was just so there until it was
taken from us and now
mouths are just everywhere and they're
tempting and you just look at someone's
mouth you know like before you kiss
someone you like look at their mouth
like everyone's doing that now and it's
made for some really awkward
you know uh doctor's appointments and
the dentist has always been weird like
that but
um yeah it's it's it's a new it's a new
world did you make out with your dentist
is that what you're saying
um i it was a while i haven't been to
the dentist in a really long time but
yes when i used to go regularly it was a
thing
okay um i have a question
well it is weird at the dentist their
fingers are like in your mouth
conan this i wasn't even planning on
telling you this but i did have a
dentist that used to just like pick a
serious
station and like that would play yeah
and it would he would he would pick like
i don't know like the pulse or something
and he would be like his fingers would
be in my mouth and there i remember one
time the song was playing
you're a crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] so good i'm
on
top of it it was like if you that song
was playing as the deadest figures were
in my mouth and i just was like
so aroused no it was really uh
inappropriate
i wanna go wrong i wanna go to your
dentist
i want to go to your dentist i really do
uh just because i think i wouldn't need
novocaine
i would just be so hyper eroticized that
i'd need
nothing i'd need nothing yeah no
laughing gas just uh yeah put on some uh
i don't know jane's addiction whatever
it is let me ask you something nikki you
said something that caught my attention
you said you know when you're about to
kiss someone the way you look at their
mouth
and i i can't it's look i've you know
been a married man for a long time but
back in the day
i was quite the doll
and what i'm saying is i don't remember
staring at people's mouths before i
kissed them
i just think that's a good way
to let someone know if you
wanna like you just like stare at their
mouth and that'll let them know that
like yeah you're good to kiss because
guys don't know
yes when to kiss they don't know
especially in me too
post me two era they don't know when's a
good time to kiss i have a lot of advice
actually on this
about when it's okay or like at least i
think i know
so guys out there they're like i don't
want to make a wrong move girls don't
like to be the first to make a move
so this is what you do you
if a guy if you like a girl you sit next
to her enough
like where your arms are touching where
it's like barely touching you know like
you could
put a piece of paper in between you and
you wouldn't feel it right right so like
barely touching so that you're not doing
anything aggressive
and if the girl likes you and would be
down to kiss you
she will leave her arm there she won't
move closer
but she won't but you can if you don't
like the guy you can pull away and he
his feelings won't be hurt because he'll
be like oh she didn't even know i was
touching her yes we did and we don't
want it we don't want it to go further
okay
but if you leave it you and it leaves
flush
yeah good to go and uh if he's also
staring at your mouth and or if she's
staring at your mouth going like right
when you talk about staring at the mouth
it's like getting in this close and just
staring
and that's the sign i also want to say
that for
deaf or deaf people that are reading
lips
if someone's deaf and reading lips don't
take that as they want to kiss you they
might just be trying to
you know understand understand
understand what you're saying i'm really
glad that you quit yes but also i will
say when i want to
want to kiss i like to um uh read
braille so there are mixed messages
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
so sorry i
i had a plan here and we no no no i'm
i'm
thrilled i'm happy uh now
you are now uh i've been hosting for a
long time you're hosting this show
you can't say much about it but you're
hosting this show right down in the
cayman islands which is
basically you're describing the gig i
want not the gig i have
it's a dream what do you learn i am on
i've never been on location have you
ever been on location going to where
you're like
it's like summer camp where you're with
people for like over a month
and you forget about there's a world
outside of the show it's like this
bubble it happened to me on dancing with
the stars where i was like
i got kicked off dancing the stars i
actually i got um
well i got first uh voted off is how i
like to say it but
i as soon as i got off the show i didn't
know how to like
walk around in the real world i was just
like i can't i was like dancing is life
and i can't do anything else i can't go
back to comedy because you get convinced
that that's all that matters
right and i'm on the show right now
where yeah it's intense have you been on
location before
i haven't uh the closest i've come is
space doing travel shows but no then i'm
always on the move so no i haven't
done i haven't done that kind of gig and
now what i'm curious about is now that
you're hosting
what are you learning about yourself as
a host what is
what is nikki glazing like as a host
i've been watching other hosts
obviously i my goal is to be a team like
i love tv hosting
you are a huge influence on me um and
pretty much no one else like i i'm
obsessed with you and um
i know and i've seen i've and you are
one of these heroes that they meet where
you go oh he's not as good as i thought
he's gonna be
you're just as good if not like better
and more personable
like off camera at least to me thank you
but then
you find out and you're you seem to be
good to the people you work with like
from what i've seen but
you find out when you talk to like the
crew and get to know these people who
have worked on sets
that the stories that seem cartoonish of
celebrities having these egos of like
no eye contact on set things that you
think are just
mythical are actually real like there
are celebrities that
you and i love who you and i probably
have met before who would only be nice
to us because we're celebrities but they
treat people like trash and they
literally will not allow eye contact
there's several
people that i don't want to name because
i'm scared of them and they're powerful
but
i i find that to be so uh just
disheartening and awful and so i try to
be really nice and have like a
connection with everyone the crew
so i to to juxtapose that i i've started
when i arrive on set
i make each crew member have four to
five minutes of uh deep connected eye
contact with me
and it's slowed down production quite a
bit we're about
three weeks behind at this point and
i've fallen in love with one key grip
and two gaffers hr complaints
but and i don't really know what hr
stands for i'm assuming it stands for
handjobs rule
i i don't know but well uh i haven't
looked it up either i don't
think that's what it means but uh until
i look it up
i can't be 100 sure you can't be sure
no one can really be sure what hr means
so i um but yeah i've just made
an extra effort to be nice and to make
people who are working on the show
feel a part of the show because there is
just this divide
of celebrities and it's not just about
the celebrity thinking they're better
than everyone else
a lot of times people just put that on
celebrities and i'm not even speaking
for myself i do this too
where you you don't you see someone in
public that you really admire and you i
don't want to bother
them or i don't i don't want to tell
them how much i love them because they
hear it all day
but because of that everyone thinks we
hear it all day
and so no one says it to us right i
literally had to call
like the executives of the show like my
bosses and go you aren't complimenting
me enough
and they go oh well you're great we
figured you knew
like how we gave you this job and i go
i am a celebrity because i am so
desperate for
love from strangers and anywhere i can
get it
you will never give me a big enough big
head where i it will never be enough so
please
please compliment me and i've done that
in my own life like i
know that you know i write about the
bystander effect in
the one day i went to my psychology
class in college
and i wasn't hungover and i learned that
kitty genovese in 1964 was stabbed to
death
38 people heard her screams for help no
one called the cops because everyone
thought someone else was calling the
cops we do this all the time
oh someone else will do it and then no
one does it and you
she bleeds to death on the sidewalk and
and and that's what it's like when you
don't tell me my hair looks good i'm
bleeding to death
no it's not as extreme but you're
comparing you're comparing you're like
you're com you're saying it's the same
thing it's pretty much the same thing
and i'm not disagreeing
but it's the same thing that uh you not
getting enough praise
on the set of your reality show is
pretty much the
same as the stabbing death of kitty
genovese in 1964.
yeah i i um those are i'm saying i'm
it's exactly the same yes and um
and yes so thank you for understanding
me there's there is no
uh nuance here or exaggeration yeah i'm
being literal i feel yes uh just as
abandoned but
conan do you relate to that i mean you
must because even when i'm around you
i hesitate to gush about how much i love
you
um and what i think of you because i'm
just like he hears it all the time he
must he's like the funniest person
he's not like he is the funniest person
alive i've always said that
and that's but do you do you relate to
that conan that people
sometimes don't say something to you
because they're like you hear it all the
time and you're like no
more well that's the problem is that uh
it it's a no-win situation
because um what happens is first of
all if it's someone like you like an
attractive woman
that's all i dreamed about when i was a
kid and in my teens and through my 20s
and then well into my 30s was
a very attractive woman complimenting me
that was my dream
so that's not going to go away i'm not
going to lie
i love that but at the same time
what happens is self-loathing kicks in
and so you compensate
for it and it gets very complicated and
so what i've found is that compliments
don't last
compliments are like tic tacs and when
someone says something critical
that's like a roast beef dinner that's
in your belly for six months
so i don't know why like you can get a
thousand tic tacs and you don't feel
anything
but then one person says one thing
uh and you never forget it
i don't know why it's crazy but that's
why i don't read
comments like i missed so many positive
youtube comments saying how
much you know they want to have sex with
me
and that and maybe saying that i'm like
pretty funny for a woman or whatever
uh and i miss all of those things that
really build me up
because i don't want to read the one
thing that says she's a little too
raunchy for me that's that's the thing
that i get is people
people like to give you compliments i
know you've had this where they're like
oh my god i love you
my dad doesn't get you or like yes they
have to like
juxtapose it with someone that like i
get you
but this table at the comedy club i was
watching them the whole time they
hated you how lame are they why did i
made them why do they think you need to
know that why do they think you need
to know i don't know that someone else
doesn't like you
exactly i'm telling everyone out there
don't don't count your compliment with
uh something else negative no one likes
it that way
and also like i people stopped
telling me that like i people always
talk about my comedy special i do talk
about sex a lot it's not because i'm
like
i just want to challenge people and make
them uncomfortable around their
family it's because it's like what i
want to talk about that being said it
does make people uncomfortable sometimes
and i get that
stop watching my special with your
grandma people are always like
can't watch nicki's special with your
two-year-old it's like
who's watching adult comedy specials
with their family surrounded by them
this isn't
[Laughter]
nikki many times when my kids were
younger i made the mistake of saying
let's check out nikki's
yeah let's let's let's watch out let's
check out nick bangin
and uh and and they would be like what
is it i'd say it's pretty much like lilo
and stitch
and it never went well it never went
well
my son uh you know is scarred for life
that's the point that's the question you
read your comments and your comments are
uh or when people tell you about them
it's
um i would like to have sex with her and
that makes perfect sense
my thing is people who really like what
i do
and are big fans with me none of them
want to have sex with me
that's not it they don't i don't get
that
the people who love my work say i love
his work and then if you said would you
like to just hold hands with him they'd
say
absolutely not absolutely opponent
it doesn't translate listen i don't have
that thing
i will not let you as someone who is not
a fan of conan
outside of you tell me how i process
my feelings about how funny you are
because you
i don't want to say anything out of turn
but it does equal sexiness
and someone asked me the other day what
celebrity is your
uh hall pass and i gave it what did i
say my friends here i gave it to conan
and dave matthews
oh you're kidding i don't mean to make
things weird but like yeah that's not
weird
you know what i love you waited till you
were out of the country to tell me this
that's what i feel safer telling this to
you now you waited until you had
if you came after me you'd have to
quarantine for two weeks what i love is
that you told me during a pandemic you
waited
until it's during a pandemic you're on a
secluded island
in quarantine and we're doing this over
zoom
and then you say and you say like by the
way you're my hall pass and it's a
24 hour it ends in 24 hours
that's fantastic that's a great hall
pass thank you
i don't even have all that i mean i'm
not even a relationship but i do want to
correct you and say
and for any man who's listening that
like aspires to be
as funny and as prolific as you are that
it
women are attracted to funniness i mean
right funny
it doesn't work the same way for women i
think i've talked to you about this
before like men aren't like she's so
funny like i
i want her i want to be inside her it's
more like just
like guys aren't turned on by funniness
but girls very much are well
first of all it's hot i disagree a lot
of a lot of men including myself
are very turned on by uh by by women
that are
funny and make us laugh it's a huge
that's a that's a huge deal
i've just noticed that whenever the
world's most beautiful women are
interviewed
these supermodels they always say what
are you looking for in a man and the
first thing they always say is i want
him to be funny
and then a year later they always marry
the same douchey club owner do you know
what i mean who just
happens to be worth a billion dollars
and is the least funny person who ever
lived
and they're like you don't know what
he's like when we're alone conan yeah
he likes it he's so funny he knows so
many limericks um oh my god like i
that that to me is you're you're right i
funniness is
first and and as a comedian i think that
i i can say that and people will believe
me but
you know i i don't feel like i can rest
on just being funny to attract the right
person i do feel like i have to do all
the other stuff and
right you know it's it's a it's a fair
balance but i do i do think that they're
i hear what you're saying yeah women
don't really show their work when they
say they're attracted to funny and
uh but but i will you will okay we'll
get to that later
much later i have to talk to a a lawyer
and
it's it's very complicated i got to talk
to my wife and then
three lawyers um i'm so sorry to your
beautiful wife
who i've stalked endlessly to be like
what can i do to be like her
how can i know how you guys met i know
the scene you shot together i know your
whole
love story it's very sweet well one of
the things i love about her is that she
would watch this
and and find it really hilarious like
that's her good
she would find it really hilarious and
um
she would anyone who professed their
love for me she would take them aside
and go
uh you're welcome to take a shot um
you'll you don't know what you're in for
should be like uh you can if you want
but
i gotta tell you there's there's
troubled waters there
you know are you sure you're a nightmare
i mean
in many ways no no i just i i really
yeah so but i am looking for i'm single
i'm 36 and i
am you know i'm i'm trying to assess
these things that's why i
i offered that up so quickly is because
i do i'm realizing like i
i'm starting to place different value on
things that i need in a relationship for
a man now
like i really want a man who is okay
with
like he can cry he goes to therapy not
not uh not cryotherapy just because you
watched one
joe rogan youtube clip where you learned
about a breathing
wim hof breathing doesn't mean you're
ready to be a
like a giving lover and have compassion
um but i want a guy that like works on
himself
i go to therapy i recently stopped
because i realized i was
too emotionally advanced for the men
that i was like wanting to
men need to catch up a little bit and
i'm not saying that as a dig men
obviously don't go to therapy as often
as women do because you guys are
you know society tells you that you're
not supposed to feel and men are really
scared to go to therapy that they'll get
in there
and you'll be sitting across from like
an old woman with a phd
who's like listening you're feeling
she's jotting things down and she'll be
like okay i heard everything and she'll
close her book and go
um i i have like a diagnosis you're
you're gay and that she'll have to go
and you know what i have to tell
everyone
in your life because it's just my job
and that's what i have to do
which is not all your co-workers which
is not a therapist job by the way
it's clear you know nothing about
therapists and now i have to tell
everyone because that's the therapy code
yes that well i they really think that
there's going to be some admission in
that there
that will make them like the scaredest
thing that heterosexual men fear is like
i might be
gay you know it's just a dumb fear
obviously this is a joke but i think
that there is something to that and i'm
just telling you like
men if you go to therapy and you cry and
talk about your feelings you won't
it's not you're not gonna be gay she's
not gonna like open your eyes up to your
gay and if you are gay that's great too
i would really appreciate
that and because i don't want to keep
dating you and have you take out
your aggression on my my [ __ ] um
i um
i i really couldn't commit to that joke
i gave off i was like it's too much
conan's kids might be watching no no no
my kids won't see this i'm just now
checking the rafters
the whole cro the whole crew just ran up
into the rafters
everyone was completely everyone was
completely blown away by that
you know it's interesting though like
it's do you find that the men that you
dated in the past
probably needed to go to therapy they
that's always the reason
you know and and it's nothing like i
don't need you to fix yourself it's not
going to get fixed we're all
just be working towards it acknowledge
that you're doing
things aren't working for you anymore my
my ex-boyfriend
we broke up i think because of that
mainly and
because i couldn't stop talking about
him on podcasts um but and breached his
trust a lot but
also he wasn't going to therapy we
started hanging out again we're friends
again
and the other day he was like oh i got
to go at three because um i got therapy
and i was like
really like i was like oh my god and he
goes oh no physical therapy and i was
like
oh okay he was like i go what for he's
like oh my god my shoulder and i was
like
how he's like oh i punched a wall
because i forgot to dvr the good doctor
i'm like oh yeah don't look into that
burst of aggression that has nothing to
do with your anger towards your father
let's just keep
living like the way you've been doing it
so he wasn't you for a second though you
thought he was going to therapy and you
were
interested so horned up i'm going to
need physical therapy for how quickly i
dropped to my knees and started
buttoning his pants when he told me he
was
going to possibly address his complex
emotions
god well you know what you've you've put
it out there
that because there are a lot of people
that would be very interested in dating
you
nikki a lot of good people and you've
put it out it's good
you're putting it out there that you
want a guy
who's done some of the work and is open
to being
emotionally available maybe exploring
their stuff
seeing a therapist tying me up
like wait wait
that was part of the therapy um
you've lost your uh you've lost your
earphones 30 times during this interview
but i had to borrow some from people
because i cannot keep my own
and they are far too big for my time
again i have the very tiniest ear holes
oh man that's
the biggest turn-on for me it's just
they're so
tight a q-tip makes me feel no i
i don't even know but i i that's nobody
by the way that's nobody's turn-on i
have the tiniest ear holes
it's not i literally went to the ear
nose and throat doctor because
my voice is just like i i sound pretty
rough i just got
i'll i'll say that i went to the ear
nose and throat doctor my doctor was
like
very hot and i didn't see it coming and
i would have like prepared because
whenever i'm around a hot guy
i make sure all my holes are like in
working order not those because i was
like at the ear does
he put in a thing and i have like too
much wax
i don't know why i'm just like a waxy
gal and he looks inside he goes whoa
you do you ever use a whenever i stick a
q-tip in it literally looks like i stuck
it in a baked ziti like it's
i i just make
it was so embarrassing i was like do you
want to check any of the others they're
good
yeah um no i'm looking for a guy um and
i'm working on myself
and i honestly i wanted to like put a
call out there on
your show so anyone watching you're a
fan of conan
i'm a single lady here's what i'm
looking for someone who's emotionally
uh involved someone who's uh
doesn't have to be funnier than me just
has to get my jokes if you like conan
you're gonna get my jokes
um and then also looks wise i can be a
little shallow i don't mind height i'm
height blind i don't care i like a short
guy because if you go for a short guy
you can tend to get hotter guys if
they're shorter like on discount
it's like it's like you know getting
like a
designer sweater at marshalls like it's
like overlooked by most people
so like you can get hotter in the face
if you you can get a 10 in the face if
you go five seven in the height
is what i found but so height doesn't
matter but like i like how
women always tend to describe men's like
physical traits that they like
based on like athletes so if i was
building my perfect man it'd be like a
like swimmer's shoulders like runners
legs and like a golfer's [ __ ]
um i don't know what that means that was
just a dumb joke what is that
laugh i don't i don't i didn't know
i just wanted to be able to hold uh
these
earbuds in place i want it to be the
same
size as mine what am i talking about
oh my mom and dad are watching you can
call you can always call them and say
um the conan interview got cancelled
don't watch
that's true but they love you too much
and they also
they they hit your parents they came by
the show
they came back my parents are the reason
i'm cool they're much cooler than i am
and my dad took me aside when i was in
i think seventh grade it was like there
is a show that i just came across it
last night it was your fifth
anniversary special and he he taped he
he taped it uh on vhs and i watched it
and
i just you know told you this before but
i just it was this moment for me where i
was like
something out there you felt this way
comedically about people it's
i'm i'm understood the things i've been
laughing about and want to laugh at
are being done and this is just i
watched your 10th anniversary special
last night
oddly enough and was just reliving some
of the greatest moments and
uh yeah i'm just so grateful you're
still around and will continue to be
around and like i just
that's really i mean calling you my
friend is one of the greatest gifts of
my life well
uh you will see the same thing which is
when you put this stuff out there it's
only because i've been doing it for a
long time but when you put stuff out
there
you're gonna meet so many young people
men and women who come up to you
uh and you're not even aware you're just
doing your thing right now and then
they're going to come up to you later on
and they'll say
when i was seven when i was 10 when i
was 15 i got in trouble because i
watched you and it really like connected
with me
so you have no idea how many friends
you're making right now
and you hear it all the time from people
but it's just it just goes and
to me that's the nicest thing about
being in this business absolutely that
you know the money's not bad but that's
the best part that's the best part yeah
and i want to make sure i
mention that you have this great podcast
and you're doing it daily now which yeah
i do one once a week and
i can't imagine doing it every day
that's got to be
well you do this show every day yeah you
know and that's
that's what i'm trying to do here is i
don't have a tv show right now
that i'm doing daily and i i just love
the idea of
you know i grew up watching a late night
you
letterman just people you hear every day
and i love morning radio shows getting
to know like a group of people so
and i just want to get those um 10 000
hours in i like working i'm not doing
stand-up right now
so wait it's an outlet it's a really fun
show it's called the nikki glazer
podcast
it's on iheartradio podcast but you can
get it wherever you get podcasts um
and it's with my best friend i move my
best friend from new york to live with
me in st louis which is where i've been
since the pandemic i got a place and i
moved my best friend in to live with me
we recorded in my living room it's so
fun it's the most fun i've
ever been having and i just like i like
working every day and i'm i'm
looking to you know do this the rest of
my life and i just want to get as good
as possible and you've got to get those
reps in and i mean
but i wanted to say it following up like
you i know that someday i'm going to be
a certain age and people are going to be
people that i admire are going to be
like oh my god you're the reason i
stepped on stage the first time but i
got to say going in like
you're one of those people that you
you're you're
the return hasn't diminished on you with
age like sometimes people take a step
back you're still
as funny uh funnier than ever and it
just is really
it's it's nice to be a conan fan you
keep delivering and there's just endless
content and
i i i really appreciate you there's a
huge podcast is just a new level
of fandom and i'm sorry but i just got
to get these compliments in
okay well that it's really sweet now i'm
determined to
really really disappoint you so hang on
for that that's coming soon
you just can't um well let me make sure
because your podcast is great the nikki
glazer podcast
is available on iheartradio and it's
doing great that's what that's the worst
i'm doing really great
and it's just me and my best friend
andrew collin i live with him i
i'm a 36 year old woman who chooses to
live with a 40 year old man who's my
best friend
we're both straight we're both single we
are not having sex everyone's like
you're mar
you're getting married and i'm like no
we're not we just live under the same
roof we
share a dog together and we don't have
sex so we are happily married
[Laughter]
you understand marriage is better than
anyone yeah well make sure you check out
uh nikki's podcast on i heart radio and
wherever you get your podcast and listen
to it because you're gonna love it and
nikki
thank you always a joy talking to you i
can't wait till we're in the same room
again me too and we'll talk about earwax
extraction because q-tip is the worst
thing you can do
right it just like shoves it back in
yeah okay i know that yeah i know that
you gotta go see someone and get it
pulled out and then you can keep it and
you can make a candle
true story is that real no
my q-tip i just realized looks like you
when i pull it out oh
really yeah yeah it's long and orange
yeah it really does
all right nikki glazer you be well and
have fun while you're there okay
love you conan thank you so much see you
next time bye
it just came out again